a birthday party ended in a shooting
early sunday morning five people injured
and sent to the hospital it happened at
a home on holt avenue near lake mead
boulevard in nellis 8 news now reporter
ryan matthey spoke to the people living
there and neighbors on what they
witnessed
a birthday celebration ends in gunfire
my wife checking the
window i checked outside they look at
the police metro police surrounding this
northeast valley home overnight sunday
five people were shot neighbors say a
fight at the gathering escalated into a
shooting i saw about 10 police cars
lined up
on this street here
i'd never seen that before so i knew
something had happened calvin border and
other neighbors were awakened by the
police presence a source with metro
confirming to 8 news now about a hundred
people were in the backyard when i asked
the residents for an explanation of the
shooting they declined to answer my
questions they actually said they were
unaware of the shooting until they saw
it the next morning on the news they
call this an isolated incident the
surrounding neighbors say otherwise and
they have this house party once or twice
a month
on saturday nights it's pretty you know
pretty often you don't have concerns
that this would happen again i really
don't know what's what's gonna i i
imagine they might put a restriction on
the parties there
from now on that's just my guess
but you know it's uh
things get wild on saturday night
ryan matthew 8 news now
one person is in custody he's been
identified as 36-year-old alberto santa
cruz police would not comment on the
status of each victim and the
circumstances leading to the gunfire